make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay what's going on guys this is Rob
and today we were gonna upload we were
going to release um
Excalibur I think it was as the second
video or one of the x-men dawn of X
videos I think this is more important I
was thinking about Doomsday Clock number
12 and I was thinking about all the
things that led up to Doomsday Clock and
the more I thought about it the more I
thought there was this thing that DC did
not really explain or at least it didn't
seem like they explained and it was
basically why dr. Manhattan could not
see past Superman right if you go back
and look at all the old Doomsday Clock
comics right issues 1 through 11 the
idea the overarching theme was that at
some point like it seemed like a fight
was gonna break out between Superman and
document happened that Superman was
going to lunge at Manhattan and then he
looked like he was going to punch him
and in that moment everything went black
for Manhattan and the question was why
couldn't he see past Superman why
couldn't you see beyond Superman -
whatever was it was going to come next
and it was it was kind of intriguing
because I kept thinking about this and
thinking about this and thinking about
this and I think the answer is a lot
more obvious you know insofar as is what
went on and maybe it's just one of these
things worse like the overly obvious
answer that I just didn't pick up on and
that kind of seems to be the case but it
was it was intriguing to me because I
was like why can't he see past him and
so I kept thinking about that right now
I've won back and ready issue number 12
you know I was like maybe we can find an
answer here and now I was looking
through it and I didn't see one right
like I you know I mean you get the
moment where Superman comes lunging
towards dr. Manhattan but it's to
basically defend Manhattan from like
somebody else but at the same time it's
kinda like okay but like why do things
go black that was the question I
couldn't find an answer to so I'm in
Lexington for the week of week of
Christmas and I'm hanging out with my
editor Gordon and I'm hanging out with
Mariah and we're driving out to
somewhere I don't know where where it
word is that we're going to but we're
driving there and we're I picked up
issues 11 and 12 of Doomsday Clock cuz
she's reading through issue number 12
because I'm proposing this question to
them and I'm like maybe I missed
something so more is coming through the
comic he went to comics interlude over
on Waller Avenue for those guys who were
familiar with that you know she's
looking to the comic she's like no I
don't really see anything that says it
explicitly and I was like that's what I
thought right there's no clear-cut
explanation there and then her and
Gordon actually came up with a really
good explanation kind of going back and
forth with each other and talking about
it and the idea was that the reason why
Manhattan couldn't see beyond Superman
was because man hadn't made a choice and
and and it was it was one of the coolest
things right it was like dude this is
like this is a really really cool idea
right so so bear with me bear with me on
this when you look at Manhattan
throughout DC Comics and look at him
through like the Watchmen comics look at
the
look at him through the lens of the
Watchmen Manhattan despite all of his
vaunted power is a slave to time right
that's best the the the way this whole
thing works is that Manhattan perceives
time insofar as the past the present in
the future are all happening
simultaneously right now it's only in
relation to himself my only relation to
what's happening to him right so he
doesn't really see the past the present
in the future in terms of how it affects
some guy on the other side of the world
throughout like his everyday life it
doesn't really work that way right he
can't really like jump back and forth
through time so we can't leave the
current moment and then like travel into
the past and then like do his thing his
hours don't work that way and so it's
it's it's like okay so like if that's
the case like heating he never really
acted never really cared because in his
mind everything that that he sees in the
future is going to happen right there's
no way to get around that there's no way
to get past that things are irrevocably
locked into that future and so as a
result of that it was just kind of like
you know like humanity's going to go to
war these things are going to happen but
we saw that kind of play out with with
like the Watchmen college right like he
couldn't see past this one particular
moment that was gonna take place but
like Ozymandias and everything now of
course I ended up being like the giant
monster this released and all hell
breaks loose and and so on and so forth
but it was interesting because if that
was the case if Manhattan is is himself
a slave to time and he just kind of
looked at the future and says the future
is etched in stone and it cannot be
changed then what happens when he
encounters a circumstance where the
choice of what comes next is explicitly
left to him and nobody else is left it
to only him and nobody else right like
he determines what comes next and that's
kind of the cool thing is because he had
made these changes over the course of
the DC timeline right he moved the
lantern away from Alan Scott and so Alan
Scott didn't it didn't didn't you know
get the lantern when he was supposed to
and instead he died in the train crash
and as a result of that he never became
the Green Lantern and the JSA never
formed you know because of that simple
action all the way after the 31st
century the Legion of super-heroes never
existed right so you see all these
little things that go on this this huge
cascading effect this starts with a
simple thing and all of it was
predicated on the idea that Manhattan
looked at the entire time Street and
said well if the flash Barry Allen could
travel back in time save his mom's life
and then create a whole new universe as
a result of that and if somebody like
the anti-monitor can can wipe out most
of the positive mannered universe get
into a conflict with the specter and by
virtue of their actions lead to the
destruction of the current universe and
the end the formation of a new one right
you know if if superboy-prime can punch
his way out of the pair
nice to mention send ripple effects that
basically alter reality
and then the multiverse can be reborn by
the actions of Alexander Luthor then why
can't I change time and if I can if I
can change this universe on a
fundamental level by altering a couple
things here and there then what would
that look like well you know how those
things unfold and and under normal
circumstances that would have just
continued on whatever that timeline was
going to be right you know how
everyone's going to unfold headmen had
not said everything back it would just
kind of continue on and continue on to
get to anyone and as the reader we were
expecting Superman to lunge towards
Manhattan and punch him and kill him or
Manhattan to just wipe everything out of
existence or whatever the case was but
in that moment when he's watching
everything go down with Superman
and when he's inspired and Superman
Superman literally tells him he's like
you know maybe this darkness you that
you see maybe it takes everything that
you have to save the world maybe you
make that choice then is basically
you're making the choice to fix
everything you're making your doom
you're making a choice to undo the
changes that you made to the timeline
and to basically allow things to
progress as they were supposed to that
seems to more or less have been the case
and that's why he couldn't see past
Superman is because Manhattan didn't
know that when this conflict happens he
was going to make a choice between
either allowing the timeline to continue
on or to go back and change things and
set things back to the way they're
supposed to be he didn't know which
choice he was willing to make because he
didn't know he was going to make a
choice and because that future was not
guaranteed because the the future of the
DC Universe hinged on whatever choice he
made there was no absolute future there
right because that choice hadn't been
made it was basically a fork in the road
and Manhattan couldn't really see past
the fork in the road because he didn't
know what choice was going to be made
and so when he gets to that moment then
it turns into okay well let's go back
and undo all the things that we've done
and and in turn everything goes bad you
know goes back to the the DC Universe as
it was really kind of perfecting or
giving us this full totality of the
blend between the new video and the pre
new 52 right so the return of the
Justice Society of America the Legion of
super-heroes does this thing and and so
on and so forth well I don't know maybe
this is one of those glaringly obvious
things that all of you guys picked up on
as soon as you read the comic and I'm
like the only one who didn't get it
which is entirely possible right but
it's cool because if that's the case
that's genius writing on behalf of Geoff
Johns right like that's that's genius
writing to take a character like
Manhattan who always looked at time and
and kind of had this idea that he was
locked into it the time couldn't be
changed and
- basically alter it and then to kind of
make this choice to be inspired and to
make this choice basically correct
things it's cool right because it's like
Jeff John's always wrote his stories in
such a way to where they tied it into
like the real world
right like the emotional spectrum is a
reflection of the real world right like
we all feel rage we all feel like greed
and we all feel anger and I'm sorry I'm
sorry love and we feel like hope and
different things like that this like the
fundamental the fundamental emotions of
humanity rather come in the emotional
spectrum and the Green Lanterns and all
that's predicated on his own personal
experiences as well as things that would
be relatable to the reader right and so
as a result of that it makes sense it
kind of taking that sort of emotional
tie in well I took in that that personal
vested interest and then applying it to
the comic and then sort of shiny
Manhattan in a way that we would look at
him right and say okay so like we've all
been in that situation where we feel
like we're like we don't have control of
our own lives you know are like we're in
the passenger seat of our own life and
whatever future is coming for us cannot
be changed and there's nothing we can do
to alter the course in which our life is
on it's cool to kind of introduce that
concept you know into the comic in
mistake but you can though right like
you can at any point just stop and like
get out of the car or given the passes
are given the driver's seat of the car
and take control of your life if it's
cool to see that that kind of meta
textual commentary thrown in but again
you know I mean I don't really mean to
come across as like I'm the sole person
who figured this out and then that may
not even be the right answer
hey I mean it's just I think that's one
of the great things is there there is a
kind of kind of possibility there you
know because it's intriguing you know
it's kind of Awesome the way this whole
thing plays out but I don't know I mean
let me know what you guys think right
now let me go let me know if you guys
think I'm just being like a pompous ass
you know or or if it's if it's something
that seems to be legitimate right
because I I thought I'd be interesting
that that Manhattan couldn't see past
Superman because Manhattan didn't know
he was gonna be faced with a choice and
whatever whatever comes after that
blackness that he saw would be a result
of the choice that he made not knowing
he was going to have to make a choice
and so it's it's it's cool you know I
really I really dig that but anybody
guys where you wanting read this video
to any and just forget I would throw my
thoughts out there and just kind of see
what see what you all think I love
hearing from you all you know I love
hearing your all's at your office
thought process and yeah we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here too comments explained and make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
who's we've got some new patrons in our
top tiers over on patreon.com slash
comments explained I want to give a
shout out to Jason see Austin s Austin H
Phillip and Austin B as well as Steven Z
Eagle F Joey M and Jeff are as well as
Genesis 916 as always we just usually
keep the last name - an initial it helps
you guys to maintain your anonymity some
of you guys are expressed concerned
about having like your first and last
name thrown out there for the world to
see I do not blame you for you guys who
have joined up as part of our patreon
tiers that are eligible for Rob core
honor guard rings those whose rings have
been sent out you should already have
them if you're a new person who just
joined up and you've been part of this
here for a month your ring will be
mailed out to you so I want to say thank
you guys for being patrons
[Music]
you